[Music]
in chill out news chill out like an ice
cube man submitted by Jove ahlian statue
cleaner
why are you submitting articles get back
to [ __ ] work yeah that's right
scrub that ball what's his position L
I'm the treasurer secretary Treasury no
Steve yeah is that what he told you you
were yeah I'm sorry are you sure I don't
think you should manage our money I'm a
dumb a change the position I don't think
I do I think you do I just have the
title and I just came out it's just like
a class yeah he isn't he isn't he is
what do you call it a [ __ ] checker
yeah yeah quality controller I'm down
that I'll be national parks advisor some
[ __ ] so she has get an air-conditioned
building yeah he makes sure that
everyone is [ __ ] scrubbing the
statues yeah I just want don't check
that's it a woman was arrested after
spitting and drunkenly yelling at
passengers on a flight Oh like an Air
Marshal got up and [ __ ] tackled her
ass
how come there's all these flight
incidences and I never hear of a single
Air Marshal come out how many air
marshals are there like supposed to be
one on every flight he does a budget
colonel yeah there was no Air Marshal
when that crazy lady came like doing
crazy [ __ ] in my plane yeah so weird I
hear of this urban legend that there's
an Air Marshal in every flight it says
certain commercial flights maybe there's
like really important ones
I think post 9/11 there were on every
flight Oh maybe they got tired there are
not enough air marshals to cover every
flight so there are assignments are kept
secret
no one knows which passengers well I've
never heard of one then mm-hmm like in
all our stories it's never like oh this
was intervened by an Air Marshal that's
so true and do an emergency landing
they're definitely not doing Fresno to
Arlington or something Fresno gnarly
yeah domestic flight because it's like
you know they're probably gonna go on to
the ones that's like New York to LA or
some [ __ ] what if you're the Air Marshal
and then some [ __ ] happens like where I
don't know like that congressman
wouldn't give up his seat to the
comedian lady and so he stays up in
first
and then she's like bitchin and then
there's like an argument and then people
are like getting a tussle or something
and then the Air Marshal reveals himself
he's like I'm the Air Marshal on board
or everyone needs to calm down and then
terrorists attack and I know who the
[ __ ] air marshal is they were just
waiting for the Air Marshal protocol
probably you don't wanna flush yourself
out it's like a game of mafia you want
to lay back wait if I just want to watch
what's going on yeah they're like oh
this seems like a just some kind of
activism going on let not my lane not
mine I'm waiting for the [ __ ] of
biological weapons or some kind of
immediate threat real threat Oh does a
drunk person puking on another person
not my job yeah that's interesting cuz
right now I was reading like myths about
air marshals and one of them said this
is a myth that federal air marshals get
involved in every dispute at the airport
no they don't because in November a 2013
when a TSA officer was shot by a lone
gunman at LAX the Air Marshal said not
my job bleeding for more than half an
hour and later died and but they say
that a team of fire air more I'm sorry
federal air marshals were less than a
hundred yards away from the shooter yet
they failed to respond or engage in
threat how did he have an explanation it
was not my job just like we're not in
the air right now in action was quote
mostly due to a mentality and unwritten
policy that exists at the fans by upper
management that tells air marshals not
to get involved I called this [ __ ]
they're waiting for a real threat bro
well what's worse than this guy alright
so at what point where they need to
escalate above shootings people so like
someone goes in the airport and starts
shooting a lot of people they go doesn't
seem like much of a terrorism does that
look like a domestic dispute to you yeah
that's a that's domestic violence a bomb
no my job but it's a pipe bomb he's like
no that's two small balls it's two small
ball I mean local police officers are
supposed to handle those disturbances
and fans must maintain anonymity during
missions they're like come on man we're
supposed to be your name stir just be
ninjas here can't
blow our cover me me all these like for
narcs city sitting in their court in
Chile ligand he'll assist Olga's job
you're a federal agent that doesn't have
to do anything I'll be shot in the
airport in the air it's a different
story they had they do get involved only
if it's crazy as [ __ ] still yes there's
only after ability to handle a situation
what are they getting involved with
called all of this they could have their
[ __ ] eye covers on nothing oh yeah no
they get involved mostly with the
beverage service you know I mean like
what the [ __ ] is going on up there
mostly I'd sleep a lot yeah I do a lot
of sleeping sleeping reading there's
like arguments going on fights there's
that one guy that was on the airplane
and he was trying to get his ass wiped
by the not be like not my job I'm not
wiping his ass cuz what's he gonna do
he's like yeah I'm Air Marshal on board
yeah calm the [ __ ] down
he's the only one with a gun in there or
maybe we have heard of them of fire
marshals doing [ __ ] but they just
because they want to remain anonymous
you've never disclosed that they're far
whatever Air Marshal
Fire Marshal hey listen fire marshals
fly to I was with you really undercover
no no did you make is that I was like
damn they got fire marshals and damn
dude what are they be doing on the place
what if they had like mob guys all kinds
of guys and then it's like sometimes
you're in a whole flight full of
government lights are so cool yeah but
you're the only one that's just not
government you know any all right so let
me tell you the story
okay so this took place in Fort
Lauderdale Florida this passenger was
removed from a JetBlue plane they were
headed this flight was headed to Las
Vegas but this woman she got upset
because she she became disruptive after
she was she found out that she was gonna
be sitting next to a three-year-old
she's like I'm not sitting next to a
[ __ ] three-year-old I've been drinking
all day so that's what Valerie said
who's 32 years old and so she was filmed
yeah
[Music]
don't touch my shell get all the please
get my [ __ ] off the [ __ ] underthings
[Music]
there's more to the story - tsunami is
everyone going to Vegas yes
she's just partying early huh today I
like the part where they leaving then
everyone claps I don't wanna play with
my petty ass would have just left her
luggage in the airplane and then just
[ __ ] snail mailed it under thing the
under theme I would take it out slowly
wait a couple days and then asked USPS
to deliver it alright so on her way out
of the flight she farted no she wanted
to re-enter the plane nope can't do that
you can't that was the JetBlue agent who
tried to stop her and then she hit this
agent on the head that's why she went to
jail a soul and a 32 year old passenger
told deputies that she also struck her
on the arm when she refused to switch
seats with her Bush that passenger did
not want to press charges I would have a
thousand percent yeah then he got to the
point where like we were trying to
detain her to the full extent and she
kept spitting on on all these like
deputies and then finally there is no
they were requested a spit mask but by
the time the mask came she stopped
spinning
she stopped spitting and so they didn't
use the mask
I'd do it anyway handcuffs and had leg
restraint and so she was seated in a
wheelchair damn this girl's out of
control Hannibal Lecter getting taken
Jesus she probably didn't have good
parents she's dead post bail but she was
jailed for there goes our gambling money
everything remediation she's gone there
alone to Vegas I think she's a hooker
not anymore but she was going a lot I
think she's alleged hooker okay or
stripper
only those two possible she gone there
for a bachelorette party could be a
Golden Nugget stripper maybe maybe yeah
I mean you mean the ones that are just
like dancing on the pool while you play
blackjack like oh go go dancers not to
Planet Hollywood chicks because they're
pretty it's pretty good stuff but the
thought maybe she's off stripping like
[ __ ] calico Joe's or some one of
those like yeah old school that's
nothing you know in that place mediocre
strippers almost like a gold mine earth
only it's like two teeth left
yeah overalls and [ __ ] I miss that big
is the Old West Vegas I like to feel on
the theme but I love the theme [ __ ] man
I mean what happened - what was that
Excalibur some shadow show an interest
in casino dude tyka would love the
basement of the Excalibur where they
have all the hard stuff it's just a
total kids land just all of it I'll be
tight but it's probably really [ __ ]
dirty it is really dirty oh yeah can't
attest until you get rooms for 20 bucks
roach infested rooms for 20 bucks get a
suite for 4500 yeah and the non-smoking
room smell like it's been pop boss like
7,000 times I'll get the Presidential
Suite for [ __ ] $75 hell yeah and like
you can do whatever you want - hey kid
vomit in here whatever you have we can
jerk off on the floor whatever you do
whatever you wanted in with the
Presidential Suite it probably all
smells like cigarettes and alcohol on
the rug I'm regretted regret loving
every shoes and baby tears tears yeah
yeah all the [ __ ] rooms that people
have gotten killed in or like got
literally jumped out of the [ __ ]
thing or yeah you know what's even
crazier I was on this form of like for
Vegas right and into as a hotel worker
and they're like what's the worst thing
you've seen well sometimes a person
would commit suicide and then would have
to clean it up because it's a busy
convention weekend and then they were
checking into the [ __ ] room
immediately an hour oh my god right
after somebody died a cup
hours ago that's a testament to how
effective those cleaners are that's
right yeah tip your cleaner oh yeah
that's what I'm saying oh yeah when I
touched those linens and I'm like I was
like no one's dieting man there's so
much [ __ ] that goes on in here but I
feel fresh and I smell it and it's
always smells cleaner than anything I
own sometimes buried in my own room
I don't mind it easily someone died
there
just moments ago but that's how clean
they are it's so clean it's probably in
every hood home I mean think about how
awesome they are they just someone just
[ __ ] took a [ __ ] on the blankets and
barf and then this hotel that in put in
Istanbul I was sleeping and then in the
morning I saw the sheets and it was
disgusting see cuz that's it's that Bowl
we're talking about Louis see see see
that's it's that bowl they didn't do it
right what was with the pillows stains
all over not stains but it was just like
a lot of human hairs like Paul like it
was hairy and they weren't blue hair so
you like comedy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]